where there are times you were an
[ __ ] to someone and you regret it at
the chess board or Beyond yeah so I'm
asking internet questions yeah I mean
this is definitely true I'm not gonna
pretend it isn't when I when I was
younger
um I was very angry when I lose games on
the internet
um many of these stories are
specifically from the internet of course
and you know I think I look back on it
and of course I I wish that I'd been
able to like channel the anger
differently basically I think the simple
gist of it is I would play Blitz Games
online and I lost I would get angry at
my opponents instead of getting angry at
myself
um which of course it's silly because
they're playing the game they're trying
to win like why shouldn't they try to
beat you I think for me like I'm not
happy about that when I was when I was a
young teenager getting so angry over
these online games and insulting a lot
of people along the way but maybe that
paved the way to your streaming career I
think for me like I feel like having
that me against the world attitude
though it really fueled me when I was
younger feeling like it was me against
the world everyone hating me or me
hating the world the that was very
important I was able to channel that
anger in a way that really helped me
improve so like do I regret it on the
one hand yes of course you don't I think
it I think you don't want to be like
that on the other hand what I've gotten
as good as I am if it was different I'm
not so sure